c'est comme ça chaque année à quelques
jours du 9 mai le centre ville de moscou
enfile son uniforme à la gloire de la
patrie c'est la répétition générale pour
le grand défilé militaire sur l'avenue
tel ce qu'aia qui mène à la place rouge
l'armée parade avec son équipement ses
chars ses blindés et même ses ogives
nucléaires les mots ce que l'autre garde
certains sont en extase
ça ne me fait pas peur dit valérie ya en
pointant un missile balistique derrière
elle au contraire c'est la force c'est
la protection il s'est rassuré
dans notre pays chaque génération à sa
guerre à défendre dit galina drapeaux
communistes à la main elle dit que ses
parents se sont battus à berlin
c'est dans nos gènes dit elle le
combattre le mal
impossible cette année de dissocier le
patriotisme en bien d'une guerre qu'il
aura été vendus comme nécessaires et
essentielles pour libérer l'ukraine du
nazisme et pour protéger la russie
le politicien en exil guennadi goudkov
parle d'une espèce de psychose
collective nourrie par la propagande
extrême et dangereusement belliqueuses
du crémant
se sert d'ailleurs plus que jamais de la
télévision d'état pour brandir la menace
d'une frappe nucléaire sont les pays de
l'occident qui fournissent des armes à
l'ukraine
[Musique]
dimanche l'animateur vedette le mizuki
ciel y sommes sans même évoquer la
possibilité de rayer la grande bretagne
de la carte avec une pureté nucléaires
géants vidéo à l'appui
mais on a pu le président coûte que
coûte dans les rues de la capitale tout
le monde affiche les couleurs de cette
guerre en vue du mieux fou le z est à
l'honneur un soutien presque obligatoire
pour les commerces si l'on se fie à cet
homme qui décorent la façade de son
magasin malgré le fait que sa propre
fille a dû fuir les bombardements en
ukraine
mais il préfère s'abstenir de tout
commentaire
censure militaire oblige
car la russie est en guerre il faut la
gagner à tout prix dit nicolaï qui ne
montre aucune empathie pour les civils
qui meurent sous les bons jeux savent
que pousse évidemment
milliers sont déjà morts dit il
froidement un peu plus
important selon
sauver les soldats russes et ce alors
que les rumeurs de mobilisation générale
s'intensifie
à quelques jours des célébrations du
jour de la victoire si la plupart se
réjouissent ils sont impressionnés par
cette manifestation de force certains se
désole de son absurdité
attaquer un pays voisin qui ne rien fait
pour nous provoquer et cruelle dit
pauline à une des rares qui nous
exprimer son opposition à la guerre
comment peut-on se réjouir dit elle
c'est ni beau ni patriotique pour moi
c'est douloureux
[Musique]